voilà alors les d'un état de sol qui est
très sec
voilà leur smic été fait hier la graine
je sais pas si je vais la trouver mais
aller dans la terre sèche je suis à plus
de fraîcheur du tout du tout une terre
rendue à ried par un ensoleillement trop
réguliers ces derniers mois et un vent
qui assèche en plein semi les engins
agricoles peine à garder ainsi endroit
tellement la terre réduite en poussière
tourbillonne comme en plein mois de
juillet si la germination du maïs ne
peut se faire dans ces conditions la
croissance des céréales comme le blé est
sérieusement contrarié on est sur du
blaye qui n'a pas été irrigué qui a eu
très peu d'eau on voit les l'enroulement
l'enroulement de la feuille comme quoi
c'était un blé qui est en état de
sécheresse
on voit l'état de sol qui est très sec
et puis si on arrache d'avoir ça ça
vient pas mal et c'est que la terre
c'est comme ça fait la poussière des néo
cons un des clubs les arracher la
solution bien que partiel passera cette
année encore très certainement par
l'irrigation sur une partie de ses 350
hectares christophe giroux ya recours
nuit et jour et ce grâce à une retenue
collinaire une réserve de 80 mille
mètres cubes d'eau de pluie recueillie
d'un bassin versant
il puise dans cette provision sang
prélevé dans les nappes phréatiques ni
dans les cours d'eau la sécheresse
commence également à avoir un impact sur
l'alimentation des animaux
si la pluie ne fait pas son retour il
faudra déjà entamé les stocks d'hiver on
est sur du pâturage a depuis un mois et
on n'a pas de repos parce qu'on voit
tout de suite que d'excès paturel ça
repousse parce que c'est le seul et trop
sec donc là bon dans cette prairie là ça
va tenir un peu mais les autres prairie
où j'ai des animaux dans quinze jours
trois semaines siffle pas on a rappelé
herbe tous les agriculteurs scrutent
évidemment les bulletins de météo france
mais les prévisionnistes ne sont pas
optimistes pour l'instant à dix jours on
voit pas de
de précipiter précipitations importantes
et au delà pas de tendance vraiment
significative donc pour l'instant rien
de prévu
chez christophe giraud dans l'est du
département de l'indre et loire les
dernières plus remonte déjà au 15 mars
avec seulement 18 petits millimètres